Speaker 1: All right, these are my favorite
clips today.
This is so funny today on the bonus show,
when I'm joined by producer Pat, we will talk
about how suddenly Rudy Giuliani's son, Andrew
Giuliani, is running for governor of New York.
And he appeared on Fox News last night and
gave a completely bizarre and farcical interview.
But Eric Trump didn't want Andrew Giuliani
to outdo him, apparently.
So I can't actually tell who gave the dumbest
appearance last night on Fox News.
Let's take a quick listen.
We're going to start with Eric Trump, Donald
Trump's son, not the smartest one, I don't
think.
And Eric Trump claims that random people are
coming up to him on the street crying in tears
over how much they want Donald Trump back
as president.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: More people I mean, I can tell
you more people have come up to me on the
street in the last week and given me a hug
saying we miss him so much.
I mean, literally sometimes, Sean, with tears
in their eyes, we miss the man so much.
No matter what you say about him, he loves
this country and he's willing to fight for
this.
Speaker 1: Does anybody believe this?
Like, I do believe that tears have been shed
related to Trump as president, but I don't
think that they're tears of joy.
Then Eric Trump claims that this White House
doesn't travel.
And that that's really bad, but listen to
the complete inconsistency of what he even
tries to assert here.
Speaker 2: There's no fire coming out of the
White House.
There's no one there.
They don't travel.
They don't go down to the border.
They don't go overseas.
They don't I mean, there's no charisma.
There's no there's no anything
Speaker 1: that you guys catch that he says
this White House is bad because it doesn't
travel, it doesn't travel, and this White
House is bad because there's no one at the
White House.
Well, hold on a second.
If they're not at the White House and they're
not traveling, like, where are they?
Where is Joe Biden is that's is there is the
president just missing?
He's he can't be found anywhere.
He's not doing any traveling.
Is he at Camp David the entire time?
Just vapid, pointless talking points.
Not even really a criticism.
So that's Eric Trump that's already really
bad.
But then income's Andrew Giuliani.
He is running for governor of New York State.
This is Rudy Giuliani's son.
He's thirty five years old.
He went on TV last night and declared anything
that will bring money to New York.
He will do, period.
Full stop.
End of story.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Well, look, let's start off with
sports gambling.
I don't much how much time we have anything
that's going to bring revenue into New York.
I am pro that a lot of people that I know
go to New Jersey in order to actually go and
gamble.
Speaker 1: You really feel.
Like the Republican Party has no farm team
right now, it's Kuhnen type people like Marjorie
Taylor Green, Lauren Bobert and others, they
may be the future of the Republican Party,
but it's a really scary future.
If that's the future, you then have your Trump
brown nosers who aren't they're not even really
young, but they might potentially aspire to
higher office people like Kevin McCarthy or
Tom Cotton, Josh Holley, these types of people.
And then there's the children of well-known
Republicans, Andrew Giuliani, the son of Rudy
Giuliani, Donald Trump Jr., Eric Trump, Ivanka
Trump, the children of Donald Trump.
It's not looking great for the country and
many of them may win.
Like I'm not saying, this looks bad for the
Republican Party in the sense that they won't
ever win again.
Trump won.
So there's a very real risk that these clowns
could win.
It's just not looking good for the country.
The fact that these are people who are not
immediately and obviously disqualified from
any role in public office or in government.
Now, Andrew Giuliani seems to have sort of
a savior complex here.
He was on Hannity last night saying he will
save the state of New York.
Speaker 2: You just wait.
You wait until twenty, twenty three, and then
we're going to have a nice big party up in
Albany saying you're going to be at Empire
State.
Speaker 1: So I don't know which appearance
was more harebrained, Eric Trump's or Andrew
Giuliani's.
Now, here's a couple of bonus Andrew Giuliani
clips, by the way.
Here he is yesterday getting ready to make
his announcement.
And he seemed confused about whether the statue
he was looking at was the Statue of Liberty
or some other statue.
I mean, I don't know.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Let me know whenever you're ready.
Which one is that?
Is that Miss Manhattan or is that Lady Liberty?
Lady Liberty over there.
So everybody ready?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So that's that's something.
And then lastly, really funny, Andrew Giuliani
said at his announcement that he will use
his dad, Rudy Giuliani, as an asset.
I mean, you you can't write this stuff.
Rudy Giuliani seems to have been used as an
asset by so many people in countries at this
point.
And Andrew Giuliani apparently with no sense
of satire or parody whatsoever and certainly
no comic timing, that's for sure, saying he
will use Rudy as an asset.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: When you've got the greatest prosecutor
in the history of the Southern District, you've
got the greatest mayor, not just not just
in the history of New York, but in the history
of America.
You're foolish if you don't use him as an
asset.
Speaker 1: So we're in for a real party here
with Andrew Giuliani running for governor.
These families, you know, the Trumps, the
Giuliani's there in a sense, the gifts that
keep on giving.
But it is a major indictment of American society
and culture that people like this can actually
attain power and then that their kids are
seen as at least possibly legitimate inheritors,
heirs, inheritors, heirs to that power is
inheritors, a word I don't know.
Certainly heirs is heirs to that power.
It is an indictment of the United States of
America and the world sees it.
They laugh.
We've said it before.
Truly, truly horrible stuff.